good morning good morning good afternoon
everyone
and thank you for coming to to listen to
me i tried not to be very boring uh i
know it's the last talk
and it's been like a long day for
probably most of you so yeah hope is
interesting
hey here just
i was presented i'm gonna be talking
about
yeah what is the modern data stack what
is data ops what is important to have it
in a startup or not tech company and
with example of how we use it in in
solar learn
where it's i'm i'm data office team
leader uh to scale and optimize how we
use data in in in the company
um
the agenda for the targets well first
i'm gonna present a bit what's solar
learn vision mission and why it's
so important that we keep data to
accomplish and how do we use data in the
company to accomplish this vision and
mission
and to give a bit of the context on the
talk
then
i'm gonna
present like what is the technology and
infrastructure part of of data ops
then more about the modern data stack
the tooling and finally about
some explanations about how should we
organize all of the process around
people to make all of the data ops and
data science collaboration uh successful
uh
the vision of the company we're coming
with solar learn is to give better
career choices for all to make
programming languages accessible to the
people so we are a startup in the tech
world
the mission
is make learning simple and the strategy
for this is that everyone is served
their daily dose of learning customized
of their goals preference and potential
and of course like for doing these
things like customize personalize
knowing what are the goals preference of
our customers
data is it's key it's at the core of of
our value and that that is why it needs
to be treated as a probably one of the
most important assets that we have in
the in the company normally when we talk
about data and as i could see in most of
the conference that we had today and
yesterday we talked about data science
machine learning like all of the cool
stuff that you can do with modeling
and
but behind
all of that you need to have a really
a complete like daytime data
infrastructures and really strong
processes to make that possible and that
is where the data ops concept
is introduced now
so what
data ops does and and why essentially in
data ops what we do is
take care of of the data platform which
is all of the tools a technology and
process
to take the highest value out of the
data
and why it is important as i said like
data especially in solar learn it's at
the core of of of of our value
and
it what makes
it what it will make us different from
our competitors and it will will also
help us accomplish that
mission and
and vision and
why it's important also to do it as soon
as possible like in the whole process of
skating in the company
it is because if you don't do it at the
very beginning or the middle states then
you start getting a lot of problems that
we will we're gonna see after
and that
um
makes like that the data people in the
company especially data science data
analytics teams are focusing on
knowing where is the data rather than
using the data for
for getting a useful insight for for the
business
um
there are two things that we're going to
talk about here about like data ops it's
a technology and an execution or the
technology and infrastructure which is
like
essentially
a treating data as a product
so
as
a we are normally
used to hear about like how do we should
do product management know like how to
interact products
managers with engineers but data should
be treated essentially as like kind of
the same way no we need to build a
with discipline and rigor around how
data is transformed governed
documented so that there is a real
portfolio of gold products in the
company this is means data models tables
dashboards that are trusted and
acknowledge a single source of truth in
in the company and
and also we will talk about like the
people and processes to make that happen
as with when there is growth in a
technology company there is also like a
need to
generate ad hoc and reputable analytics
to assess and execute a strategy and
product like normally like analysts will
be embedded in the different product
teams and there should be a strong
processes to know how to interact with
this data of steam to to make that
happen um
i don't know what i did
okay so technology and and
infrastructure
and
normally like in in in a startup and
this i i've seen it in in like all of
that like all of the companies where
i've worked
for it's like we start with a
a small data team that when this company
scales they just do almost like
everything now and mostly like the first
hires of a startup are data analysts or
data scientists and at the very
beginning there is not a lot of data so
infrastructure is not a problem but then
things start to scale and they are like
all over the place and and doing all all
over of kind of processes that maybe is
not what an data analyst or a data
scientist should be doing in their in
their day-to-day so these are like three
of the most common problems that
i've seen and what data strikes tries to
talk token tackle a first like repulse
pro like there is not like when there's
not like a single source of truth for
for the reporting there is like a lot of
analyst building point solutions but
there is not like a broad portfolio of
trusted tested certified source of truth
for decision making
analysis overdue er this means that
there is like an over effort of the data
analyst team
analytics team as they are not just
focusing on
uh
giving insights but they are also like
spending most of their time querying to
get kpis and not doing root cause
analysing so
like the data scientists in the end they
don't have like a clear platform where
process data build models or deploy
predictions and attempt that it is
managing those those kind of processes
and lack of governance has
it's difficult to have a single point of
contact that is responsible for owning
the data models and the data governance
of the of the company so knowledge is
totally spread around the data analytics
data science team and there's not like
where
one team or one responsible like when
you want to know where is that where are
the data and what the data means that
you can go on and ask those questions
and and in the end this leads to
unsuccessful integrations and and
and then the data assets sometimes leads
to comforting and again i
don't know why i'm breaking that this
all the time
this one
okay so now we've talked about kind of
the the problems
but uh it's also important to to talk
about the the solutions too so
okay if we see those problems and this
problem sounds familiar to you in in the
places where you work like how how would
how should we solve them and what data
house can do for for it so how we
enhance data inform decision quality and
decision speed that that is the main
mission of of the data of steam and
first of all like not to have fear to to
rebuild things like if if the data
infrastructure is not uh it has led to
technical depth and it's not
able to quickly scale the data the data
products with the business demand then
there's my recommendation it's like not
to have fear for build things from from
ground up and not trying to use the
existing systems and the legacy systems
and and rebuild them um
again it's like uh to to
put like a data house practice in in the
company
um especially like if the data science
team as we saw this is it's been mere
down with ops activity like building the
data model squaring against the
databases that are
not suitable for for
for for scaling and going fast
uh
so
i would recommend to build a specific
team within the company that has this um
mission of just taking care of the data
and also take a lot of care on on the
governance part not only like building
data models but also building the the
documentation and and the centralized
place where people can consult and and
and understand what is going on with the
data inside the company
so in
kind of like the solution statement and
back is and relating the solutions with
the with the problems that i was talking
before for the
reports pro problem
uh data ops to own the data models asset
creation and the back of cell search
analytics
for the analysis overview is
reducing the data science overhead uh to
improve the decision quality speed and
building gold data models like when i
say about gold is that our models that
are tested every day that you know that
those are like the single source of
truth
um
for for for all of like the business
stakeholders of the company
and for the lack of governance it's
important to implement
version control and code reviews for all
of the the sql model and transformations
that are happening in between like from
once you get the data until you saw it
in a dashboard or or in a in an analysis
in kind of like a
conceptual approach like and how this
like relates with the different teams
and and the the goals like and how you
should build things from from scratches
it's like a top to bottom approach
a first you have like the strategic
needs of the company what are like the
different goals like
increase the number of customers number
of orders it depends on the objective of
it then you have those goals that are
related to each of like the teams of of
of the company
and each of those teams
will be like looking at their main
reports analysis dashboards that
reflects the kpis and metrics that are
linked to the
goals above right and
behind those dashboards reports you have
the different the data data models
that depend on on the data platform that
the data the team
creates so all of like the work of the
data ops team
that should be like creating and
maintaining those data models are always
and should be always linked to the
strategic goals of of the company you
know and that's how at least like in the
end you you
prioritize the work and you know uh what
what you should be doing at every time
no um so
between this uh technology and and and
and processes and the problems and the
people and processes that that we will
show us later it's like the modern data
stack that is like my main point of of
the dog which has all of the tools
a and and i'm going to put as an example
like what we are using in solar learn
to to solve all of the issues that that
we saw in the previous slides
um so what is the modern data stack in
the end it's like a new approach to data
integration which is essentially a set
of tools
that saves engineering time by
automating processes and
not yeah saving in them allowing data
engineers and analysts to pursue higher
value activities for the business rather
than be focusing on like
more like tech problems or
infrastructure problems that in the end
is different difficult to
connect to the
business holes that we were seeing in
the in the previous slides there are
three main verticals and tools when
when we're talking about the modern data
stack uh well there can be more but it
can be summarized in these three
and
the first one is
data extraction and and and loading for
that you have like kind of two different
approaches that can
you can choose one or another one or
combine them
actually that combination is what we are
doing in
in solo learn
first is like tools third-party tools
that they have pre-built connectors to
like the different data sources and
this is very recommended when there's
like a few people and it's difficult
sometimes to hire data engineers and and
you not have like that many resources to
to serve like all of the goals of the
company and
those tools are like fully managed by
the third party tool and you just need
to like worry about what are the source
data that you need to connect and put it
in the in the data warehouse and and
transfer them accordingly and then you
can also develop all of these connectors
in-house
which
normally has the
advantage that is less
costly because you don't need to pay
like a third-party tool for doing that
but you also need to maintain it and
that it's also something that you need
to
in the end get up get a balance no
and then the second part is well now i'm
going to talk about the
the data warehouse
before talking to the transformation but
like before
like some years ago the tendency was to
do
etl which is extract transform the data
on the go and then loading it into the
dv or into the data warehouse and then
using it but with the evolution of the
data warehouse or delta x i saw that
there was a talk about that
today
and that the computing power that they
offer right now is amazing and then you
are able to query
tables with billions of rows
in seconds
the tendency has shifted more into a elt
approach no you extract the data you
load it into the data warehouse or to
the data lake and then once you have the
raw data you transform it to adapt it to
your to your business
and so yeah the cloud computing and
warehouse um which
is essentially a database but the main
difference is that the the way that they
store the data is
columnar so that's allows for
queries to be more optimized and and
more fast
and it's where we dump the
the raw data from from the extract and
those processes and then
the data transformation
part
um which
it normally made with with a tool that
or with sql modeling or even pi spark or
python depends on what you use but the
the key here is that there should be a
tool that allows you for version control
for documentation and that it's very
easy to
go backwards and know
what what is happening with the data
and if you don't take care of that and
you don't use the appropriate tools and
and this approach in the end you will
have like a lot of hostile procedures
uh and
you will not know who has made changes
to those stored procedures or
and
it's very difficult to like to read the
dependencies across all of the data
models that that
that you build
and
this is the example of the tooling that
that we use in solo learn like i mean
you they're so like the important
is not the names like these are like a
few examples uh but there are like other
tools in the market that are similar to
these ones
um but yes for
us in solar end for the etl tools what
we use is a five strand a combination
between five strand and databricks
fivetrain will be that this third-party
tool that has pre-built connectors
and for us it's just as it's just we
need to integrate
the data from google ads or facebook ads
or paid media so getting into our
account there and dumping all of the
data into the data warehouse and then
figuring out how to transform it or we
also use databricks for
other connectors
that five trans doesn't have in their in
their
assortment
and and their in database we built
everything by our own code
and
our data engineering in-house effort
then
for data modeling and transformation we
use a tool that has become very very
famous and very used in the last few
years by
a lot of the tech and startup companies
which is a dvd that is data build tool
essentially it's a
a platform where you can
put all of your sql code and also
combine it like similar with python with
a language called india to make the code
more usable and unreadable
and this is a um
yeah a tool that keeps the person
control of all of the sql
transformations that you that you do
inside the data warehouse allows also
for monitoring alerting and
documentation of what that is is kind of
like the central piece of our what we
call known data stack for data warehouse
and data lake we use the google cloud
platform option but there is you can
also use the amazon one with red shift
or azure snowflake which is a agnostic
in the in the cloud provider
and
we in in our case we just be query
because
um
it is serverless and we do not don't
need to worry about the configuration of
the servers for doing all of like the
the queries and
makes things much more easier for for us
in the point where we are
then a business intelligence tool for
doing all of the reporting in our case
we use power bi there's a lot of options
there in the market like tableau
looker whatever you want to use there
then for
a well i forgot to mention that in the
extract transformational load
there's the combination of doing in a
batch way which is
just doing
extra control information on the data
once twice a day
but not keeping it like in real time in
the data warehouse but if there is a
need
to have the data in real time in the
data warehouse that's also possible with
the streaming etls in our case
we use kafka
we don't use kafka in-house we use
confluent cloud which is kind of
kafka managed
but it's the solution that we're using
for for having this a streaming data in
in real time in in the data warehouse
and then
a data workspace collaboration
for the data science team
to a connect to the data that is
transformed and build as golden products
and and report layers in the data
warehouse and this allows them to just
query the data and build the machine
learning models or more complex analysis
for av testing experimentation
with python with pi spark with the
language that they that they want
but yeah
in the end it's different kind of
toolings that automate part of the
process that they don't make us like
build everything in-house with the time
and effort and cost that that will
entail and that make us like made us
create a data platform in less than six
months uh that is useful for for also
for the data science team to focus on on
developing all of their insights this is
kind of an overview more visual on one
of the tooling that that we use so we
have here like the the data
data sources that normally comes up from
the client side which is the apps
android ios wipe
and
the back end
and then also we have like all of the
third tools
that
when we connect them through their apis
and that they also provide like data
that is not um
like in-house it's not data that we
create that they create but that is also
really important for us in case of like
facebook ads google ads like how much we
are spending in marketing iterable which
is the tool that we use for
communicating with the users and make
them make
send them push notifications
or apps flyer that it's the tool that
connects what our user does with the app
with all of the marketing campaigns that
we are running now like saying this user
has done this inside the app because of
this campaign that you've run and it has
like a lot of data that is very
important for for us and for the product
teams to to analyze
um
some of the backend data and the
client-side data goes to streaming to
the different kafka topics and then
going to the to the data warehouse with
with a connector and some of this data
of
the sql server and
and the applications that if there is no
need for going under streaming they go
on batches
with the databricks or with five tran
depending if python has the pre-built
connector or not or we do a balance of
like what is the effort and cost for
each connector and then
everything goes to the data warehouse
and in
there we have like three three levels
uh we have bronze silver and golden
layer the
bronze layer is the raw data so it's
data that
goes from the source to the data
warehouse and
we do that really basic transformation
to make sure that the table of schema is
it it doesn't change it's the same
but then we have
it's where dvd enters in place that it
has it's connected to
to
github in our case for version control
and
then we build the
silver layer which is also the other
name that we use is staging which is
kind of a one-to-one relation between
the row table and the
silver table and here we make sure that
strings are strings
integrals are integrals like the basic
transformations or if we receive a json
or a payload in the raw data we unnested
and we create like the
table structure that
that we want and with the naming that we
are comfortable with
and then we built the
golden
layer with doing all of that merge or
joins between
the silver data that we know is with the
with the structure that that that we
want
and this fact and and dim tables is the
the one that come from the golden layer
and then what difference of factual and
dimensional tables factual is just
something that
happened in the past and you cannot
change it retroactively in the sense
like for example a user has completed a
lesson in india this is something that
happened it's a fact and each row
represents that that event and
dimensional tables are giving extra
information
uh to to the factual
variables and those dimensional tables
can change
with time
for for instance information about each
user id how many lessons they've
completed in the last 30 days like this
is some variables that are updating all
of the time
and
and then we have a
la
our last layer which is called the
reporting layer that it's uh
once you have like all of the factual
and dimensional models you create
aggregated reports
in order to make the
data visualization tool that we use more
efficient and optimal
but the key thing here is that yeah all
of these transformations happen
within inside the data warehouse
using the computational power so it is
very fast and not and
and not very expensive
and
everything happens in a collaborative
environment between like all of the data
engineers and analytics engineers using
using github so in the end what we know
is that all of the factual and reporting
layers are
tested are monitored because you can
also set up
money monitoring and testing alerts
within
a dvt they have like revealed
like to test it that they are not new
values that all of the values of a
column are unique or the count of a
specific variable it's the same of the
count of that means same variable in
other models you can be very creative in
the way of you how you test and monitor
the data
and
and then the data science team they
don't they need like kind of forget
about doing all of this and just
focusing on using our visualization
tools and analysis tools to
to to create and
gather the insights for for the product
teams yeah
of course that's kind of an ideal world
there's always like collaboration
between in between the the two the two
teams especially because yeah we really
need to align on what do we build in
this in this kind of models
um
but yes this is our how our current data
platform looks
uh when in the future we might also
incorporate any
other things that
they can also like be integrated in
inside like the modern data stack
especially like
two two important kind of tools the
reverse etl and like ml platform or mlx
platform um reverse ctls are some tools
like these are some of the examples like
sensors high touch like there are a lot
of them but what essentially what this
reverse tools etl tool does
it is querying the data from the data
warehouse
and putting it back in some of the tools
that we use
to
make the process more
data driven so let's say we want to
communicate with all of the users that
has completed a lesson in the last
uh two days and that specific lesson as
we are doing a lot of the
transformations here
that
aggregated data is in our data warehouse
is not in our in our main
database
so with this kind of tools you can
connect the warehouse to
these tools and make data driven
decision this is not something that we
have right now but
it is also an approach that a lot of
companies are using
and then the ml platform with the
normal ml cycle
for that we will probably use a
databricks but the important thing is
that the ml platform is connected to all
of the golden models and reporting
models that the data of steam creates
so
and then like when once you have the
the the model built you can use it to in
again actually create more data-driven
decisions there
um
okay and now talking about more uh
the different like people and and
processes aspects like when what's the
problem when you have like a data
science team or a data analyst team but
you have not built
a
a data option or a team that is just
focused on that um
like three
there are three things that we need to
talk about first of all like the
workflow
a like defining who does what and what
are they like the the different roles uh
inside inside the team this is crucial
if not it creates like the misalignments
and and problems then well focus also
like in the transition um
as normally like the data the the data
teams like first hires have built all of
like the knowledge around the
the
the the tables and the the
data models that that the that the
company is using
and like how how do we shift to the new
new place now when there are like two
separate teams and one is dedicated
fully to this and the other one
it's not and also create an appropriate
resource plan like if there's there's a
new to hire someone new um who like i
said what role is responsible for what
what's the technology that we need and
and invest on on it
in that aspect like i guess like it's
really important to
differentiate like what are the
different drugs and responsibilities
that the data of steam should do um
like
there can be more but the three
um the three most
important ones are to differentiate
what's data engineer analytics
engineering and envelopes
engineers um
for data engineer the key focus area
it's to operate and optimize the data
warehouse and and data lake and their
focus is more about this first like when
they when we were seeing like all of the
schema of the data platform the left
side no like how do we ingest the raw
data how do we create this bronze layer
in the data warehouse and also
making sure that the
staging layer like the bronze to silver
follows follows the
the principles and the standards for for
for the for the company
they built all of the data integrations
manage the pipeline orchestration and
they are responsible for managing
day-to-day pipeline processes and
resolving abstract upstream issues as
needed so they decide
if we're going to use a stream but like
what is the most efficient way to get
data into the warehouse then analytics
engineers
they focus more on transforming the
silver the data into gold a products and
the under reporting and reporting layers
to standardize kpi measurement
they
provide consultive support and
stewardship on how to access data as
well as governance and overall data
architecture like they also responsible
to they are responsible of the whole
data model of the data warehouse and
doing all of the documentation and
knowing what what's going on and doing
the transformations on the most optimal
way and been in contact with the data
analysts and the product teams in order
to to deliver that and then the
envelopes engineer part that will still
current don't have in the or not doing
so in solar but that can for an advanced
data of steam it's an important role
that is to maintain and operate the dml
platform and infrastructure
the development and deployment cycles of
machine learning models like once the
model it
works will happen with a model like
provide the infrastructure to
train them to put it into production how
the engineers are going to connect to
that
envelope to serve all of the all of the
predictions
and final well there are
two
different processes
uh that are important and how data ops
engages with with them first one is like
kind of a standard business engagement
there's like a need like there's a need
to change a dashboard to add a new
variable
that team like has an analytical
question to solve if this can solve by
the data science team data analytics
team embedded in the product teams
then they use those products that are
already built and everything goes as
normal if not then is where the data of
steam er
enters in the question
the manager
should pro
facilitate the intake process and
discovery to understand what is the the
impact of of that need and prioritize it
accordingly then create the product
requirements with the product teams and
finally execute on a sprint planner
become an approach it depends on the
company and the other one is when
there's like a new product feature and
there's
something new like it's not something
like an improvement on something
existing like then the
everything starts from the
product requirements document the prd
then
they
the data analysis along with the product
manager they define
what are the requirements the analytics
requirements for that new product
feature and then the data ops a team
they facilitate a discovery of of
and to understand what are the
implications of that prd
if that means that we need to create new
data or
it will create some changes in the
existing data
then we go to like this flow of doing
all of the data engineering and
analytics engineering work
in able to finally have like the dvd
reporting layer all of the models there
so once the product feature
it is released the data team has and the
analytics team has all of the models
already there and if not then continue
as normal with the product development
without implications of the of the data
upstream
uh yeah this was the last slide
uh it was a lot of information but thank
you and
if you have any question
please stop
[Applause]
thank you for the talk it was very good
i have a question regarding the
architecture that you have shared uh you
mentioned that for data processing you
are using data breaks
and for data lake and data warehouse
capabilities you have uh
i believe uh maybe i mentioned uh maybe
i'm missing bigquery right
yes like yeah we we choose those stack
um we use data rights mainly now for
data engineering purposes like we have
the code the code builder for
a connecting to our sql server and then
putting the data into bigquery yeah we
don't use databricks for data
transformations which could be another
option and this is something that
we investigated using the
delta lake of databricks and you can
also connect dvd to
two there
it's also a really good solution but we
decided to go to with bigquery
um have you considered dataproc other
than databricks for uh pipeline
development
yeah that was another option to use the
the
google cloud platform tools for for like
using also like the data block that it's
like similar um
yeah and we consider but in the end a we
we like like the ui of data breaks how
it works with the proof of concept we
were happy with it
but of course this you can also use all
of the gcp tools for doing that like
this
yeah i see and the last question um
maybe i missed it i do have uh date
quality checks on your pipelines yes
like that happens
in dvd
so dvt has
pre-built a
test for for checking the data quality
normally like we do
most of the our checks in
in this phase like when
well when moving from raw data to silver
layer it's where we do most of our
quality checks i see yeah thank you
any other questions
okay thanks everyone
okay
thank you for your talk
you mentioned that you use dpt for
version control right
but i see git too like
how much
version control provides dbt
if you are additionally using git tool
well the version control is provided by
by github
which is connected now in the end dvd is
kind of like repository of sql code but
it has can has like a lot of things like
macros or preview packages but when i
say version control is that
every sql query that we do and when we
want to do a changing any of the data
model
that is reflected in github and we have
like a pull request process so
i cannot just go there and change
something and no one
could see what what has been changed no
it's someone from the team needs to
review it understand the implications
also when we do
a pull request there is an automatically
there's an automatic trigger
that
um
builds all of the models in a
development branch and see that there
are no like
conflicts
so when we merge new code we know that
we are not affecting
and breaking anything on the go yeah
which is very important because we are
now maintaining more than 300
data models
in a data warehouse so
once especially when you are doing
changes in the first part of the
pipeline
you can think that that will not break
anything
but it can so it's good that github
allows us to to do that trigger of
also like running all of the tests in
the model to make sure that we are not
creating duplicates that all of those
things
thank you
yeah
currently what we do is we have like two
different process like for the
well the streaming goes into real time
all the time then
data breaks on five
five ten they happen like once a day
it's like the batch process it's like
very
early in the morning
and then
we have the all of the dvd orchestration
that is triggered a
half an hour after the batch process it
is a
currently is not automatic that trigger
you we could
automate it with airflow for instance
that would be possible but
current we know what is the time that we
update like all of the data models and
we put like half an hour
to orchestrate all of the models in dvd
but with dvd
it's very easy to say okay run the
these models or just specifically these
models and the cool thing about dvd is
like
it automatically reads the dependencies
so you don't need to think about that
like
it knows that this table is built from
this table so it knows that this table
needs to be built before and they don't
allow for cyclic dependencies so if if
you create a cyclic dependency it will
give an error and it will tell you
has
a connection so you can connect five
train with dvt and that will be
connected but in our case i don't know
we have it separately but yeah i agree
that that's that's a risk
we also have
in dvd we have a source
alerts like we have alerts on the source
and
every time the the pipeline runs it
checks if the data has been updated
and if it's not been updated it gives
you an error so before starting the
pipeline we know that the data is
updated you know
that's how we're going to work
thank you